yo you've been so good at building
Brands um I just saw Vibes clothing
launched uh I got a pack shout out to
the homie luck uh who sent me some gear
um but you've just been so you have a
knack for brand building and that's a
talent um you know cookies obviously is
one of the most recognizable brands in
the world at this point um it's getting
bootlegged everywhere I go to I go to
the Santi alleys there's so much fake
cookie [__] yeah man [__] it let them be
our two right right right go yeah it's
like a [__] billboard for you at the
end of the day uh you go to the goddamn
whatever liquor store I mean I made a
liquor store Shady Shady just empty bags
for sale for a dollar a piece you can
get you your cookie bag and stuff
whatever [__] weed in there shady as
[__] you've seen those right that yeah
they even have like fake Grinders and
fake like uh [__] there there's been
some cool ble [__] I've seen but like
yeah we we're probably like one of the
most number one boot Lake Brands out
there but well in the weed space you're
definitely number one yeah for sure but
even like on the clothing accessor side
like I'll see like fake bongs and all
kind of crazy but you know at the end
day it's like [__] dude that makes me
feel good cuz if people really want to
take their energy to kind of bootleg
what I'm doing then it's like that means
you're doing something if the brands are
not getting bootleg I got something to
worry about they should worry about that
I was going to ask you though in terms
of like brand building what are some of
the things that like
you could give some game on in terms of
maybe if somebody is starting a new
business maybe it's a coffee shop maybe
it's a pastry line maybe it's you know
what are the the the kind of the general
things that you know you would uh you
would say are important yeah I'll give
you guys like three and then the rest
you got to buy the book I got a book on
the way uh but pretty much like first
thing first is you got to find your
identity you got to find your logo and
your identity you see cookies got that
Circle C and we got the font on my hands
you want to find your script you want to
find your identity
think second thing that's important is
like find a color way that sticks out we
can paint that building blue and you
know what it is even in markets where
like they won't let us call to building
cookies I just painted blue you know if
there's a medical Market we opened up
West Virginia we couldn't put no signage
in there but that [__] is blue they
know exactly what is so find your
identity find your script find your
colorway and I think the third thing is
like you better be Hands-On with your
[__] because if you're not Hands-On with
your [__] you're never going to actually
really own or understand your [__] you
could pay agent to build this for you
can do that for you you can pay people
to do marketing but if you ain't really
on the ground building that [__] then
it's not real that's some real [__] most
people like you said they'll I I feel
like a lot of people will settle for
whatever shitty design they get back
from the graphic designer they pay the
first time and they well I pay for this
even deeper than now I got hundreds of
employees and some of their jobs will be
like to go see quality and comment and
quality but like when I see something
I'll like can you set up a call with the
partners for me so I can call I'm like
yo this looks really good and it Burns
pretty good but I feel like we can do a
little better and I feel like we do ABC
FG that could really bring a whole new
product out you talking about the flower
yeah but I don't really know like if I
even have time for that but I do it and
by calling them directly they respect
the [__] out of it and they're fired up
that even paying attention what's coming
out of a random market right um and so I
just feel like when you put that work in
yourself then people will respect you as
as that brand and you'll actually know
what's going on with brand I could be
clueless sitting in this building right
now it's but yeah cookies is great man
we're [__] the biggest and the best
and yeah [__] rock on or I could be
the way I am anal about everything let
me see it oh man we could change this or
this store feels good but we should do
this or like are you are they doing
sales every week are they you know are
they engaging with their customer I'm so
Hands-On with everything from like
design to flower to new products to
launches of products to Partners to you
know drama going on here there I that's
why the business is still what it is is
because I know what's up yeah you lose
touch your [__] you're [__] that's
that is some real [__]